[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday 14th of april
i'm cindy you the spectators broadcast
editor and your host this week on this
week's show
police fines have been given to the most
senior people in government but will
boris johnson still survive i'll be
discussing with our deputy political
editor katie force
spectator columnist douglas murray will
also be joining the show he's written
this week that he feels sorry for rishi
sunag the chancellor and that he
shouldn't have to resign
as france counts down to the final
showdown between emmanuel macron and
marine le pen in the presidential
election is the country facing a
miserable choice spectator chairman
andrew neil joins the show together with
the french journalist and elizabeth
mootee
in this week's special easter issue of
the spectator the ukrainian journalist
peter pomeranzev writes about what it's
been like to watch the war from outside
the country he's in kiev now and join
spectator tv we'll also be joined by
veteran war reporter christina lam
author of our bodies their battlefield
and finally rory sutherland has been
going down a youtube rabbit hole he
writes this week about why it's the
perfect place for those bored by
mainstream tv he joins the show
before we get going a reminder to
subscribe to the spectator magazine you
can get 12 issues of the magazine for
just 12 pounds and we'll give you a free
20 pound amazon voucher too just go to
spectator tv dot co dot uk forward slash
tv offer
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
nobody quite expected that all three of
boris johnson carrie johnson and rishi
cenac will be fined by the metropolitan
police and more fines may yet come but
when it came the penalty was not the
trigger for a full-fledged tory revolt
that many would have predicted earlier
in the partygate saga has boris johnson
got away with it again and is he forever
damaging british politics if he stays
i'm joined by the spectator's deputy
political editor katie balls
katie welcome to spectator tv
now boris johnson and richie sunak were
fined this week along with carrie
johnson but has he got away with it
again
i think the simple answer is it's just
too early to tell it's definitely the
case that had this happened about two
months ago i think that there was a
general consensus um 54 letters of no
confidence would go in we'd be heading
to confidence vote in the prime minister
um but in
eight weeks a lot has happened first you
have the situation in ukraine
you also have the fact that cost of
living has risen as an issue there and
people are hearing about much more than
parties and then you have the weakening
of rishi sunak who was seen as an
obvious person to take over i think
these factors are all uh adding to the
sense that no mps really want to move
immediately you've only had a very small
handful of mps say that boris johnson
should go you've had one minister of
resignation and therefore i think the
silent majority
are actually just waiting for now to see
what the public reaction is and to see
that if we do get into a scenario where
boris johnson receives more fines which
is entirely possible
yeah i mean also is the piece of
temporary given the fact that it's
recess at the moment and mps are not
together chatting to each other and
they're actually talking to local
associations and constituents presumably
yes i think some are even on holiday and
so he you bring that all together but
not a point where there was plotting or
a sense but it's really so easy to get
the the mood or the temperature check of
the party you have had and we've got a
running list on the spectator on coffee
house um you know well over 70 mps come
out and support boris johnson and given
there are well over 70 mps on the
payroll um i don't think that we can
read too much into it it shows there is
um you know some support for the prime
minister but i think those who are yet
to say anything um those people will
start to get more of a sense from when
mps returned to parliament i think it
would be very surprising if we end up
with confidence vote in in the next week
or so um but you combine
you know potentially a public backlash
more fines for boris johnson if there is
something that happens there are reports
he could you know receive up to three
more fines and and then the local
elections in may and i think anyone who
is saying he is you know out of the
woods uh
is probably being a little bit
optimistic
well let's talk about those three more
fines then because rumor has it that
they are coming down the line and it
does seem like this incident that he's
been fighting for this week about the
birthday cake it doesn't sound like it's
been is the worst one that he's rumored
to have been involved in yeah and i
think actually there was a lot of
surprise particularly the chance they
received a fine i think even perhaps the
chance they were surprised and those
around him and because this all relates
to a birthday cake for boris johnson's
birthday we understand it was his wife
carrie he organized the cake and the
chancellor turned up early for a meeting
and therefore was almost brought into
this uh brief celebration
now the police have clearly determined
that it breached the rules in terms of
the number of people there and the fact
it was a social occasion rather than a
work occasion but i think that as the
threshold you start to look at the other
events boris johnson is being
investigated for from the bring your own
booze party in the garden uh you know to
reports of drinks in the downing street
flat with friends of his wife carrie and
i think there is a sense and we don't
know yet of course but there is a
concern that if this is the threshold
you could actually see multiple fines
for the prime minister now it's
interesting what happens in that
scenario you've had simon hart the welsh
secretary say that for him it doesn't
really you know one fine to find free
fine ultimately the principle's the same
i'm not sure that um all tory mps take
that view and i think it could start to
get um very embarrassing if there's
multiple fines partly because i think
it's been interesting the defense of
boris johnson's supporters this week
they're really zoning in the
circumstances of this fine the birthday
cake saying you know was the birthday
even taking out the box the premise was
there only for a handful of minutes um
really suggesting that the police have
overreacted and this is you know a
trivial situation
that means they're almost setting a
precedent so with the other events uh
whether that you know it involves
boozing elections i think things which
are probably mostly find more objection
on the list of covered breaches are they
also going to say oh well this isn't
serious is boris johnson also going to
say again that he didn't realize the
rules are being broken and i think
that's why there is some concern amongst
tory mps the line right now works for
this week but will it work in four weeks
time if events don't go to plan for the
prime minister
and katie today is also when we're
hearing about this partnership with the
government of veranda for processing
asylum seekers and refugees and migrants
in order to solve the small boats crisis
first of all tell us about what we know
about this plan this partnership and
also secondly there's some who are
saying that this has come at a
convenient time given what we've just
been talking about with partygate i mean
let's start with the dead cat first lots
of people are saying you know lynton
crosby is back the election guru he is
advising the prime minister ad hoc he
doesn't have a permanent role but david
kanzini the deputy chief of staff now is
a close ally of linton crosby and we
know that boris johnson and lyndon
crosby are fond of a dead cat where you
say something outrageous or you do
something very different to move the
news agenda on and as soon as this is
announced this idea of um offshoring and
asylum
seekers to the uk and rwanda um lots of
people said well this is exactly it
i think uh given that i was told by
various people this was in the
government at the start of the week
which is actually and i heard this at
the start of the week before we got to
the fight i think this is something the
government have been thinking about for
some time and also planning to to say
this week um but that doesn't stop it
from being something which they will
hope will move their gender on from
parties and party gates
in terms of the announcement this is
supposed to address one of the biggest
political problems from number 10's
perspective which is small boats
crossing the channel
we know that number has gone up
drastically in the past year and its
particular concern in terms of um the
tory voters because brexit is meant to
symbolize taking control of borders and
i think um having a situation where you
know boats are
arriving on the shore very visibly um
really does it start to erode that in
terms of what they're trying to do the
problem has been very difficult to solve
they've been various countries we've
been hearing um you know
volcanic islands at one point where
they're talking about offshoring
those coming to the uk a bit like
australia does they have finally managed
to create a deal with wonder it's a
trial to begin with and and we believe
it will largely be men so men crossing
the channel to come to the uk he'll be
sent there
in terms of what it does it is very
expensive and the price of moving
someone to render from the uk we expect
to be thousands and that's before you
get into obviously keeping them there
what's going to happen but i i think the
sense in government is the political
price is worse than the financial price
in terms of not fixing this problem but
yet number 10 are braced for a big
backlash you're already seeing
humanitarian charities labor um saying
that this this is the wrong thing to do
and it's not treating people with
dignity
um i would expect there would be some
tory mps probably in the one nation ring
of the party who'll be uncomfortable
with this um but i think for a lot of
tory mps they're so worried about this
as a political issue they'll be quite
glad there is something to actually say
they are doing
well katie thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
in this week's issue douglas murray
writes that he actually feels sorry for
rishi sunak our brit's too harsh on our
politicians when it comes to
scrutinizing their spouses or punishing
them for success and wealth outside of
politics douglas joins the show now
now douglas welcome to spectator tv you
write in your column this week that you
feel sorry for rishi sunak uh who has
been under fire because of his wife's
tax affairs but before we get to that
let's also talk about the fines that the
chancellor and the prime minister have
been issued this week which came out
after you wrote your column what did you
make of this new revelation
well it's it's
in a way it's not a new revelation is it
i mean it's it's something that had been
expected i think everyone was waiting
for this to happen
uh and now it has i i have to say i mean
i think like a lot of people like a lot
of readers i'm very torn about the whole
thing
um
on the one hand clearly you know we were
told to follow rules
but it turns out the people making the
rules couldn't particularly follow
themselves didn't want to follow or
found it incapable found themselves
incapable of following
and that obviously is highly highly
disturbing irritating causes inevitable
resentment among i think most of the
population
then you have the issue of you know how
bad was it
the issue of the cake party the
providing of a cake
it's not
it doesn't seem to me the most flagrant
lock down breaking imaginable
uh some people who worked together as
was reported at the time shared a
birthday cake in an office
and i think there's a certain amount of
playing up of this by boris johnson in
particular as political opponents and
they're all having to pretend that this
incident was the worst thing they could
imagine and is spitting in the faces of
nhs nurses and much more and then
there's a simple fact of well the
reality of where we are
that
when labour politicians and others say
you know the
chancellor of the exchequer and the
prime minister should resign you think
really
i mean not just over this but at any
time you want to plunge our country into
a crisis like that
now of course people are saying because
of the ukraine war uh it's not possible
i'd go further than that i just say that
at almost any time
it's not possible that a prime minister
and chancellor
should be expected to resign
it it throws it would throw the country
into unbelievable turmoil
it would it would embed something that
some of us have feared in recent years
that the conservative party's
sort of reputation for
ruthless efficiency
was more just that they were ruthlessly
inefficient
um
and and i think it would be
very very destabilizing for the wider
country so i think like a lot of us i've
just got all of these thoughts at once
i don't think that they should resign
they've apologized
it's up to the voters of the next
election
uh whether or not this is going to be a
factor in their voting
um my own thought is that i mean every
year at the moment is a very long year
and
two and a half years is an awfully long
time remember just you know political
reputations are going up and down
and people are
you know the the everything about them
is is being turned on its head in a
matter of hours at the moment so two and
a half years is a long time voters will
probably remember it but it's up to the
voters to say what they think in the end
and douglas your column in your column
you say that you feel sorry for rishi
sunak now in the last uh few days we've
had allies of british synagogue actually
saying that he feels quite hard done by
by being fined because he only turned up
to this meeting 10 minutes early he
wasn't even invited he was only present
when there was this alleged cake which
some people deny happened do you still
feel sorry for rishi sunak that he keeps
finding himself in these situations
where you wouldn't say that he's
necessarily to blame well i wouldn't say
he's kept finding himself in these
situations but it is an example of a
political reputation that's just been
turned on its head you might say
actually that rishi soon as being sort
of bloodied for the first time he said
he's very very charmed career as i refer
to in my column
um he sort of rose without trace in a
way uh
and and it's an interesting it's an
interesting thing that he's now been
lambasted by the media for the first
time because of his issue of his uh
wife's non-dom
status
uh and of course the fact that he had a
green card which meant that he was also
able to work in the united states of
america um
the thing is in a way reminds me of
although it's not of
similar
severity is when george osborne was
chancellor the exchequer had also had a
very seamless rise and then if you
remember there was incident with the
deraprasca yacht uh holiday and and and
osborne was sort of mauled for the first
time was door stopped by the door set by
the media for the first time and much
more this is this is a similar thing
rishi sunak for the first time has been
really had a going over
and um in this situation of course
there's a question of uh do you
live through it
uh count it out count it as a scar and a
wound and move on or or does it show
itself too much for you now there have
been reports in the past week even
before cake gate returned
um
sorry i sighed we didn't have to say
that term but even before that returned
we had of course you know rumors that
rishi sumac was thinking of resigning or
stepping down and i i can see that
because
people in politics in particular it has
to be remembered
quite often they they feel that well
what happens and comes their way is
their responsibility for better or worse
it's the career they've chosen but
whenever people come for their spouses
or their family my observation that's
when people really start to take things
hard you'll remember that when ian
duncan smith was on his way out as um
conservative leader or a long time ago
now almost 20 years ago uh it was
actually when his critics started to
criticize his wife
that ian duncan smith was like you know
basically i've had enough of of this i
think it's extremely hard for people
because you know you've you've
taken yourself into politics presumably
with your spouse's approval and
encouragement your family's
encouragement but but when the spouse
becomes a story
uh um i think that can be extremely hard
for people and that's that's what has
happened uh i i think that rishi sunak
himself
he's a successful self-made man and as i
say in the column unlike a lot of people
in britain i admire successful self-made
people i i think we need more of them um
i don't think it's a bad thing uh that
that he's made a large amount of money
before entering politics i don't think
it should be held against him that he's
married an attractive
heiress
um you know good luck to him
it's interesting the way in which labour
politicians have responded to this
however and as i say in the column i i'm
i'm skeptical
um perhaps not for the first time about
some of the labour party politicians
claims about all this labour party
politicians consistently have
significant outside earnings of their
own jess phillips managed to make 15 000
pounds
from a few hours of filming at the bbc
last year in a vain effort to try to
make have i got news for you funny again
um where's street in the labour party mp
uh scur moral scourge uh
he he makes money now on the side as a
radio presenter david lammy uh another
very moralistic person about outside
earnings earned six figures sums each
year from his extra media work and so on
so i suspect
uh maybe you'll agree with me on this i
suspect that labour politicians mothers
think that nobody should earn
anything just above the amount that they
themselves earn and that that really
after all is the bar that they're
setting
well but let me push back on you a
little bit douglas to be devil's
advocate here isn't richie sunax wealth
not the problem some people have said
it's not the wealth that's a problem
it's the fact that even with that wealth
he and his wife are still looking for
tax loopholes now i don't necessarily
agree with that but it just seems greedy
it's the greed and avarice that's the
problem given that they already have so
much wealth well i i think that it's
it's it's it's two things first of all
there's the perception issue and the
reality is at the top of politics
perception does matter i mean this is
why we have the party gate thing uh
the the perception does matter and if
you are as vishy sunak is a a chancellor
who has raised taxes on the rest of us
and uh and you know all the costs of
living issue that we're all going
through
um it's not a good look definitely to be
involved in any
tax minimizing scheme tax avoidance
scheme if you like there's nothing
illegal about anything that he or his
wife have done
it's it's it's what people do to try to
minimize their taxes
it looks bad but they haven't actually
done anything wrong they haven't done
anything illegal and and
and if they had then that would be a
different matter
my own view and i say this in the piece
is that clearly
rishi sunak's wife was a non-dom he
should have had a conversation with her
at some point
maybe before he entered parliament maybe
when he was
on the rise maybe when he was in the
shadow cabinet let alone when he'd
become chancellor of the exchequer had a
conversation with his wife and said look
this is this is not going to look good
if this comes out
but there is one other rider to this
story which you will know
um
and and some viewers may not which is
that it is possible
that what is happening is a briefing
against rishi sunak from his own
political side
um the green card issue in particular it
seems likely that this is something that
he declared
and
he didn't need to declare he over
declared issues to do his own financial
arrangements and that these have been
leaked from somewhere within the
conservative party possibly some people
say even perhaps from number 10 fearing
a uh a rise of the man in number 11. who
knows but i think that he's i think
he'll be right to feel sore after this
but as i say this is a sort of political
blooding for rishi sunak hopefully i
mean i i i say this sincerely and as i
say in the piece i have no personal
connection with him i have no
um you know sort of
secret reason for saying this simply
wishing the stability of the country i
hope that he survives this i hope that
he grows through it i hope that he puts
it down to experience
i very much hope that he doesn't resign
just as i hope the prime minister
doesn't resign i do not think that our
country needs more political turmoil um
and i think that many of the people who
are um who are saying that sunak should
resign over his wife's tax arrangements
or saying that the chancellor and them
and the prime minister should resign
over party gate many of these people are
people who want them to go for other
reasons and and let's not fool ourselves
about this there is a continuity remain
movement in the uk there are people who
simply will never forgive boris johnson
in particular uh for leading the uk out
of the eu
many people i'm sorry to say this but it
is the case many people want post-brexit
britain to fail
they actually want their own country to
fail
in order that they are then proven right
in some way or that we will all come to
them and say gosh
turns out you were correct all along we
wish we'd listened to you
uh
this is a real um tendency sadly among
some of the commentariats some of the
political class and others
i
think that anyone who is a patriot in
britain would want stability for our
country over the settling of
frankly scores that should be put behind
us
douglas murray thank you for joining
spectator tv it's a great pleasure
france is counting down to the final
round of its presidential election and
marine le pen is within reaching
distance of the elysee what will happen
over the next week of final campaigning
and what will french politics look like
afterwards i'm joined by anja neil the
spectator's chairman who was in france
during sunday's first runoff and french
journalist and elizabeth mootee
andrew and anne elizabeth thank you very
much for joining spectator tv
now andrew we've got emmanuel macron and
marine le pen in the final round of the
french presidential elections but do you
think it will still be a clear-cut
victory for macron well we we do have uh
mr macron and madame le pen for the
second round it's in some ways a repeat
of 2017 five years ago when mr macron
became a president but
there's a lot that's different and we
don't know how different it will be yes
the personnel are the same
but there's a number of differences
first of all uh madam le pen is a
different le pen from the one five years
ago
uh she has campaigned better
she has got across her briefs better she
has a disastrous debate between the
first and the second rounds in 2017 and
mr macron well the bloom is off him
because he's now been empowered for five
years it's all been a great five years
uh he's not the uk on the block anymore
and what has always done for the le pens
both her father and uh for marine has
been in the second round the formation
of what in france is called the
republican front that all the
uh
non-national front or national rally
parties get together
and they back whoever it is against le
pen that was shirak in 2002 he won by a
massive amount against le pen pair uh
and it was macron in 2017.
i
i get the feeling and elizabeth will
know more than me about this i get a
feeling that republican front is
crumbling a little bit now
that mr macron can't quite count on it
to the same extent
that a big chunk of the left will
probably vote for madame le pen because
our economic policies are from the left
she is a woman of the left when it comes
to economic policy
and the two mainstays of the republican
front the center-right goalless and the
center-left socialist party for
presidential elections they are no more
so i would say that probably mr macron
does get through
in the second round again but it will be
a lot closer and you wouldn't rely on an
upset
well and elizabeth you recently wrote
that it was a miserable choice facing
fred the french right now tell us about
that
it's a miserable choice because a
majority of the french
i mean whoever gets elected in in the
runoff uh the majority of the french did
not want them
so that's not very good the other thing
is that what we've seen in what emmanuel
macron has wrought on the french
political landscape was to essentially
destroy the two
mainstream parties that had existed for
decades and for one of them for
centuries uh a century and a half and
it's really something very strange
because what he did he arrived he was
unknown he was to a large extent elected
by something that you could call the
populist vote
who were looking for a safe outlet i.e
somebody who annoyed everybody else who
sort of kicked out the incumbents and he
came and he was 25 years younger and um
they voted for him in this reflex
thinking well we've got the best of both
worlds which is we've got this guy who's
different and and at the same time he
comes from the uh technosphere he's an
enoch he was uh economy minister for
fosuoland for a bit it can't be too
dangerous it wasn't really too dangerous
but the real danger and nobody saw it at
the time he started campaigning for the
general legislative election that always
follows now the french presidential
election and he said
i'm going to do at the same time omento
uh you know left and right and then he
shaved off uh the most compatible
personalities from both parties the left
and the right the socialist and the
republican
the result is that he's left the
uncompact incompatible politician sort
of squabbling between one another
because uh it's always the case in
defeat that people you know angrily talk
about that that their mistakes and he
the first party to completely collapse
was the socialist party and hidalgo
who's the paris mayor and very much
unloved has scored 1.7 percent i mean
she's got some of the tiny
crazy candidates doing better than she
does and uh the republican collapsed
with valerie perez who was somebody who
looked like a safe choice until she
started campaigning in which case you
know people realized she was just not
she was not the person to go campaign so
she's got 4.7
they have bankrupted their own parties
because you need to have five percent of
the vote in order to have your campaign
expenses repaid so uh the it's it's it's
not metaphorical it is an actual
bankrupt bankruptcy for both main
parties and you've got macron who's
looking at two extremes and in his head
before he got to this point now he felt
well you know i'm sitting pretty marine
le pen can't be elected and milan is too
crazy minosho is our jeremy corbyn type
guy who created a movement on the left
of the left so to speak but things have
changed the other big upset in this
election last sunday was that milo shaw
scored 21 percent this is huge uh and on
the other side you've got marie lupin
who sort of has as andrew very well said
she's a different person from five years
ago she softened her image it's almost
more important than her platform she is
promising all things to all people you
know to the right she says i'm going to
curb immigration to the left she says
i'm going to give you benefits but just
you you know not the brown people all
around uh all the white people so all of
this makes for a toxic system and right
now macron started campaigning he was
tall people said before sunday that he
was going to harm himself because he was
not out there campaigning but now that
he started campaigning he's much much
worse he's actually doing himself some
real harm he has said the most
incredible things in two three days he's
sort of he had people he went to the
heart land of the rust belt where marine
le pen has a majority and he told them
about philosophical concepts when they
said we haven't got enough money to pay
our bills he then
met and we assumed that his people
planted a personable young woman wearing
a headscarf and she asked him a question
about feminism whether he was a feminist
and he said that she was a symbol of the
republic uh you know
with her religion and her feminism and
and the the discrepancy between the two
were very strange and the other thing is
that throughout the past five years he
his education minister his wife um his
deputy home secretary all said that
france was a a secular a lake laser
country with lacity and you know we were
neutral about religions in the public
space so he just contradicted himself he
announced just before the election that
he would uh put the uh retirement age up
to 65 years old and he just said uh
literally during a walkabout well we
might not after all he looks like
somebody who's making it up on the fly
and he's still doing the same sort of a
number of i am more intelligent than you
are to voters this is dangerous because
he might lose i quite frankly would be
unhappy to see marine le pen come in
because she
she is somebody who has no
she couldn't give names for people in
her cabinet because whenever there was a
tall puppy in her party she she cut them
off which is why all of those flocked to
eximu she's not somebody who wants to
ally herself to the republican she i
mean essentially the four national
national rally today was for the past 50
years half century managed as a family
concern and that's where we would have
and and it's it's not something good but
she sounds better than he does
well actually that's really interesting
annelida's birth andrew you wrote
recently that marine le pen could be as
disruptive and bring more chaos than
even donald trump
so would you disagree with an elizabeth
there
no i don't disagree with anything and
elizabeth said i mean i think
when it's a tough fight
this television debate i think it's on
april the 20th
is going to be
pivotal
it was a disaster for her last time it
probably won't be a disaster for this
time
it is mr macron's to lose
uh i would still have him as favorite
but as adam has been said the way he's
campaigning he's could well have the
hallmarks of defeat the way he he's
doing i mean he has tried
now to to to position this as as a
brexit issue france's version of brexit
and i don't think that matters too much
with the french people i don't think it
cuts through particularly with the kind
of voters he needs to attract
france is not does not have a majority
for leaving the eu
but it is a far more euroskeptic country
than the brits realize i mean let's not
forget that in 2005
the french voted against the eu
constitution by 55 to 45 in a referendum
when the maastricht treaty that pivotal
treaty of modern europe was put to the
french people in 1992 i was there
for the referendum and for the results
coming in the day after it approved
maastricht by only 51 percent
it was incredibly close
so i think there's very little mileage
for mr macron in picking up the eu
uh madame le pen has said i don't want
to leave the eu now she's changed she
doesn't even say i want to leave the
euro because she knows that older voters
many her natural constituency like the
security of having the euro their
pensions in the euro so she's changed on
that too
she would be disruptive as i wrote
though because of some of the policies
that elizabeth mentioned which is
she said that french law should have
privacy over european law
well you can't have an eu if that is the
case in a number of spheres and she said
that french citizens should have primacy
french nationals over others including
others from the eu well that is against
eu rules she wants to leave nato though
in my own view she wouldn't do that and
she couldn't get the national assembly
to agree to that but all of these would
cause a crisis it would be like
importing victor orban
from hungary into france and it's uh
the eu needs all this like a hole in the
head now just finally on this point
in my view this election will be won or
lost by what happens to the male and
tron vote this 21 who voted for this
marxist
unreconstructed marxist with a deep
anti-german streak in them
as well it's uh it's quite amazing
now she needs as much of that as
possible to get to 50
and i think it's a stretch
you take the
23 to 24 she got
she can add on zamur that takes her to
over 30 percent but not all of it but
you'll get a big chunk of it
and zamur has said his people should
vote for her there was another
right-wing nationalist who fought that's
a couple of percent
that still takes her only to where she
was in 2017 about 34 percent of the vote
now to get maelon she needs a lot macron
is going about it the wrong way to get
the mia long strong vote because they're
all really euroskeptic uh like madame le
pen and i just finished i i just went
through
some of her economic policies because
she is going for the left-wing economic
vote she wants to marry a right-wing
nationalist law and order with a
left-wing economics vote her policies
cindy or this british viewers ca and
yearful no income tax if you're under
30. that's quite popular
um
low interest loans for uh couples of a
hundred thousand euros to start a family
and if you have three kids the loan is
wiped clean free public transport for
the young
tax-free overtime if you're a
blue-collar worker uh
retire at 16 macron wants to take it to
65. if you're one of the less privileged
who left school early and has worked for
40 years
index pensions to inflation and have a
minimum of a thousand euros a month
reintroduce the wealth tax that macron
abolished
have a massive keynesian public uh
spending
spree and she doesn't rule out
nationalization for big companies that
don't behave the way her administration
would want
you add that up and i defy you to tell
me how that's different from milan
chong's economic program it is important
ways so although she may not get enough
to win in my view
she is being more sensible with her
campaign in trying to get that vote than
macron is who now elizabeth gave some
good examples allman seems to be going
out of his way
not to get that vote
well just finally anonymous birth going
out of french domestic politics and what
is the rule in ukraine mean for uh
macron and for le pen because
does it do people rate le pen's ability
to deal with someone like putin and
actually macron is a
statesman like parading has been mocked
quite a lot in the uk but do the french
see it differently
well the french somewhat sort of
favorable to mako about three weeks ago
four three four weeks ago because mackel
went to ukraine twice and he spoke to
putin at least a dozen times on the
telephone and in the beginning uh the
first one was a sort of solo number the
second was something in which he
consulted with uh biden he consulted
with olive schultz of germany he
consulted they said at the end even with
boris johnson
and and it looked like it was something
that needed to be to be attempted but
since then the french have become aware
of what's going on in ukraine and the
savagery of it and the sort of the
madness of king boris and it's uh it one
of the reasons why mac halls i mean
there are some reasons that macros
numbers started falling from a high of
over 30 percent
before the first round and that had to
go with that and now everybody is sort
of circulating on social media a
ukrainian joke which started on twitter
which is you we we have a new word in
ukrainian it's macaroni
macaroni micronism is basically is you
promise something many times and you
never deliver and the french feel like
that in terms of uh diplomatic
initiatives in ukraine um i wouldn't say
that ukraine is is the main thrust of
the reason why people will vote
essentially because they've seen their
bills go up they've seen their fuel
bells go up a number of things and
they're really worried but they are
aware that he was the president must be
a state of the states person uh marine
le pen is less of it even though she's
toned down this report to putin since
the beginning of the war she said that
yes she would welcome ukrainian refugees
she doesn't get a plus it's just that
she doesn't get so much of a minus
anymore it didn't harm men or sure
probably because uh
unfortunately a part of the the young
don't care what's happening in ukraine
uh but it's not something that's helping
mccoy any longer and the uh it sort of
ties into the fact that he talks big and
delivers small
fascinating things
[Music]
the french are always a nightmare when
it comes to nato uh but uh
le pen i think would be a bigger
nightmare than macron actually almost
talked as if russia should be an ally
yes
yes
and although he has attacked the
invasion she has not condemned the
atrocities which are clearly done
uh to to russia so i think it's a
dangerous situation in in her party are
at least two politicians who have
engaged with russia for for years and
years and who showed up in everything in
crimea for instance that was organized
by putin and honestly i mean there's a
horse train there's an unpleasant strain
in the hard right in france which is
pro-russian because they lose the
americans and that is something that she
embodies even though she herself andrew
was just saying earlier on it's a bit
like having victor orban uh in power
well no victor orban reads books he's
somebody who's going to finesse a
complicated position but at least he
finesses she doesn't
she likes cats
she's got a licensed debris she's just
got a license to breed them too so if
she loses
she should be allowed to spend more time
all part of this bizarre repackaging
from marina penn and janilla and and
elizabeth mutate thank you so much for
joining spectator tv
in this week's magazine the journalist
and author peter pomerantzev whose
family were exiled from ukraine in 1978
writes that he's going to keep this week
for the jewish festival of passover
peter says that ukrainians he knows
worry that the war will brutalize them
that they risk becoming so full of hate
it will eat them up inside so how can
you keep your humanity while killing an
enemy he asks peter joins me now
together with veteran war reporter
christina lam author of our bodies their
battlefields
christina and peter welcome to spectator
tv
now peter i wondered what has it been
like to watch the invasion unfold as a
ukrainian emigrate because your parents
are ukrainian but they left the country
when you are very very young
so tell us what has it been like
that's a very very good question what is
it like um
it's very hard to be
um
inside any kind of conversation
or environment where
where
your feeling of helplessness and
um
sort of guilt
um isn't
uh is increased even more so so
i'm in washington dc so i'm actually in
a world in a community where people do
care and are very involved in doing lots
of things so you can feel
that you're doing something i mean the
main thing is
to do things
and then is to sort of do them in a very
intentional way so you feel you're doing
something effective
um and dc is actually quite a good place
for that because you know a lot of a lot
of it is about
continuing support for ukraine in dc so
you can run around and
um give testimony to congress and write
articles that are read in the right
places
um it was it's harder when you go i
don't know i was in texas for a few days
for south by southwest
and in texas i'm sure it would have been
the same in the in the second world war
you know in texas they don't really know
there's a war on if they do it's
certainly not one that they
experience so that was really hard
you just you just want to be doing stuff
um and you obviously learn
not to ever ask the question to yourself
or to others
how are you doing as and how are you
feeling
because that's the one thing that you
want to stay away from and also it's
stupid as a question
um so you're constantly thinking about
doing and what can you be doing and
you're thinking about activity
and
it's been really an effort the last five
weeks to make sure that activity is
focused and is is relevant and so i've
organized this big sort of war crimes
reporting projects uh organizing a bunch
of other stuff and that gives me the
illusion of relevance and that swatches
the guilt it's all bollocks at some
level but
um that's the only way really i think
and you also write about fellow
ukrainians asking themselves how do they
deal with this hate that's
you know how do they deal with the hate
that they don't want to consume them
so yeah i mean it's um i think that goes
through through all levels of ukrainian
society from soldiers that i speak to on
the front lines
um through to senior people in the
administration
um
[Music]
they're all very aware that
no kind of justice will be enough now
you want revenge
and then the same time you realize that
you know there's a risk of becoming like
the enemy
um and i think everyone faces that
contradiction i think it's easily
resolved by the way i don't think
there's an easy fix
but i can see so many i can hear so many
people i talk to
circle around that
that that splitting really that that
really strong split that they feel yeah
and peter you're also celebrating
passover around this time does religion
offer any solace
well i think i think um
[Music]
it's a strange sort of solace
um it's a very kind of like
supposed very jewish sort of solace that
the pastor gives us and like oh this has
happened before
like oh it's another it's another
senseless mass murder that is happening
for no reason apart from uh
i don't know what is expressed as a
ethnic hatred but probably starts off as
daddy issues um so
it's is that really is that really a
solace when you realize that senseless
murder is common i suppose
makes you less
alone but i don't know if it's solace is
the right word yeah and christina
there's been more and more evidence over
the last fortnight of essentially war
crimes terrible atrocities committed
against ukrainian civilians you've spent
years and you've written your book about
how sexual violence is weaponized in war
can you tell us about that you know
people might think that this is you know
senseless uh just a few bad soldiers how
do you think that is a weapon
yes so
of course there's always been rape in
war going right back to the ancient
greeks and persians and romans but
um what we've seen in recent years is
really rape being used as a weapon of
war so people using it to try and
drive out and humiliate and terrorize
communities because they're a different
ethnicity or a different religion
and so in where it's used as a weapon
it's being used in a systematic way it's
not just you know some
guys in the
midst of war and the chaos of war and
the adrenaline feeling that they will
take advantage of the opportunity this
is actually going out there to do
you know um attack women because they're
more vulnerable
and to
really inflict
terrible
wounds and
and lasting tumor on people
when do you see that happening here in
the systemic way you know when we're
talking about it being systemic do we
mean that there are literally army
generals or
politicians who are saying this is what
you should be going out and doing or is
it less clear-cut than that
so at the beginning when the first
reports were coming in i wasn't sure
whether it was just you know a few
people doing it but now there seem to be
you know this seems to be much more of a
pattern so whether people have actually
been told to go and do it or whether
it's because things haven't gone the way
that the russians hoped it would go and
so the soldiers are angry they're
demoralized they're lashing out at
people in in the most terrible way
um i think it's you know it's too early
to know whether somebody's actually told
them go and do this or and maybe never
find that out i mean uh at the end of
the second world war during the
liberation of berlin when the russian
soldiers
raped as many as two million german
women and women across eastern europe
that was a vast number of people but we
never really saw
any actual orders for people to do that
um but it happened on a wide scale
and peter you've spent years living in
russia and you've written brilliant
books into giving insight into the
russian mindset christina just mentioned
that you know the war it doesn't seem to
be going as well as the russians hope
for
do you think that that kind of reality
does get through to people on the ground
within russia because we have heard
about a lot of russians who actually do
believe in the kremlin narrative
compared to the kind of cynicism we
might actually expect that they have
so i think there's two words you use
there which which i think we need to
pause over very briefly because i'm
literally about to start teaching a
class because even though i'm in kiev
i'm still teaching in america um so the
one is the word believe um which
which my experience in russia is is that
that's a very you know fluid term you
can believe one thing in the morning
another in the afternoon the idea of a
coherent self that is meant to have
strong beliefs in that very kind of
anglo-saxon protestant tradition where
like you go to school and they're like
what do you think that doesn't exist in
russian education
um that that isn't really certainly not
valued in the political culture you're
meant to be a conformer to who
transforms and and certainly russian
recent russian history will have forced
people to take on many different beliefs
just in order to get by um over the last
40 years maybe um so so what do we mean
by belief that's why opinion surveys in
russia are
never very good even without the fear
and the you know the bullying that and
the dictatorial elements which really
undermine any kind of attitudinal
sociology um just asking people what do
you think i mean depends when and why
and for who
so i'd be very very cautious about
making us too many long-term assumptions
about about the attitudinal polling and
about things like phone calls i mean
obviously if you phone phone someone
blindly or even your phone your parent
or something and you say things which
are very dangerous or unpleasant for
them they'll always push away at the
start i mean we know that from lots and
lots of sort of looking into people in
in
in i don't know all kinds of closed
organizations or who don't want to take
on bad news
so i'd be very very careful with that
with that word um belief um and the
other one you mentioned is cynicism so i
think one of the the way i always look
at the term cynicism and and how it's
done in a lot of sort of literary theory
it's not nihilism nihilism is when you
don't believe in anything and you know
plenty of characters from 19th century
russian literature are nihilists they're
true believers
cynicism is something else citizens
being able to switch
and believe one thing in the morning
another in the afternoon so again you
know cynicism has replaced steady belief
in russia so
the question to like to ask is
are they enjoying it
maybe are they enjoying it i look at the
emotional bit and i think a lot are i
think a lot of people are
um but but i don't know how long that
enjoyment will last i think i think
fascism and aggression
and sadism are very enjoyable
um i think many people for lots of
reasons when given the opportunity
get into it
um i don't know how big that chunk is um
and i don't know how long it lasts and i
don't know what point other things don't
kick in like rational self-interest um i
don't think empathy or sympathy will
kick in particularly strongly um simply
because it's such a sadistic culture
where you're brutalized all the time and
brutalize people
sadly you think it's the other way
around but often don't have sympathy for
other brutalized people um
so
but will other things kick in apart from
enjoyment of
uh of bullying and aggression um i think
they might because there are other
things that motivate people uh like
thinking about their children's futures
and
being very aware of the incompetence of
their own leadership after a certain
time and and just um the sense of
unfairness that sanctions are about to
really start hurting in a few months and
the russian elites are gonna be fine you
know if you've gone down to four billion
to one billion you're still a
billionaire but if you've lost your
mortgage your kids have no future
or for some bizarre sadistic adventure
from ukraine well maybe you'll start
asking some questions i have to go now
sorry i just thought i've got a class to
get so i'm so sorry
so my son was studying at some
petersburg university and
was evacuated
recently
and he was living with a russian family
a woman and her son
and she had been married to ukrainian
but he had died and the moment the war
started he told me that literally
overnight she suddenly became a real
putin propaganda
fan and started whereas previously she'd
been critical of
the idea for war and all of a sudden she
you know was literally spouting things
putin was saying and he was really
shocked to see
that and i think you know there is this
element there if people
not want you know knowledge is a
difficult thing people not wanting to
really know the truth of what's going on
because it may can make for an
uncomfortable life in a society like
that so i think it's hard for us because
we think well i mean i the first war i
covered as a journalist was the soviet
invasion of afghanistan in the late 80s
and of course then
there was no social media no internet
you know no mobile phones so people back
in russia didn't have information of
what was really going on this time it
seems very different because you feel
well surely people can see on social
media and access but
um it's hard for us to imagine that
people
might not even want to try and access
that
yeah absolutely absolutely christina the
final question i wanted to ask you is um
and this is something that you must have
thought about in your time covering
various different war zones which is
just this shifting of interest from
humanitarian crisis to humanitarian
crisis from war to war you know this
time last year we were talking about
afghanistan but as we talked about
welcoming ukrainian refugees to this
country there are still afghan refugees
stuck in hostels in the uk how do you
you know how do you think people should
and how do you personally deal with that
you know every single issue is so
important and so grueling but how do we
maintain the right amount of attention
on those issues so that we're not being
distracted by new things
that's a good question and i find this
extremely difficult because we don't
seem to be able to focus we being the
media but also
politicians that don't seem to be able
to focus on more than one
crisis at a time and as you say
afghanistan sort of overnight dropped
out of the news
um and i feel very sad about it because
the situation there has got worse the
taliban are taking advantage of the fact
that no one is looking at afghanistan
anymore and doing more
kind of taliban things that whereas
before we were wondering whether this
time around they were going to be more
moderate and more
um amenable to
a different kind of regime than
previously but now they're they're doing
exactly the same things in terms of
restricting women and girls and making
men grow beards and all of that so and
the humanitarian situation
is just gets worse and worse people are
desperate babies are literally and
children are literally dying of hunger
in afghanistan and
and nobody outside is really watching
anymore and that's terribly sad and it's
not just afghanistan i mean there's
yemen uh there's the situation in
ethiopia there are many things that are
going on that um we're not focusing on
and unfortunately i mean not only are we
not focusing on but this what's
happening in ukraine is going to make
those
situations worse because as you know we
get a lot of
wheat from ukraine and russia
and particularly some of those countries
in crisis so they
um they're not going to get
uh supplies that they need it will be
more expensive
they're already in a desperate situation
so it's a pretty bleak picture and i
wish that we could uh focus on more than
one thing and i also feel
you know it's hard to explain to afghan
refugees in this country who are stuck
in hotels still
why
british families are very happy to
welcome ukrainians into their homes but
haven't made the same offer to to
afghans i i can't explain that to people
well christina lammer hope to have you
back on spectator tv soon and thank you
for joining and earlier was peter
pomeranzev
and finally rory sutherland writes in
this week's magazine about the joys of
youtube home to big jet tv gordon ramsay
arguments and live streams of scenic
train rides as well as spectator tv why
are more and more people choosing to
watch an array of programs that don't
make it onto traditional broadcast tv to
explain rory joins me now
rory sutherland welcome to spectator tv
now you've recently been learning a
seemingly random selection of facts from
the first person to shave daily to the
population of france under napoleon um
and you've written about all of these
facts in your wikiman column this week
can you tell us why they're actually
related
um i think that effectively there is a
large proportion of the population
who are surprisingly nerdy
and who for whom facts irrelevant facts
that scipio emilianos was according to
pliny the first man to shave daily
there are certain people who find the
absorption and processing of information
disproportionately enjoyable you know
it's almost an end in itself okay
there's a large shade of the population
who'd go you know what what on earth are
you filling up your head with that
nonsense for
the large proportion of the population
for whom actually the acquisition of
information is just a source of pleasure
without any particular end
and you could say perhaps they're a tiny
bit on the spectrum i i know there are
certain writers like tyler cowan who've
claimed that actually for those people
who are slightly on the spectrum the
internet is much more of a gift than it
is for the general population
and my argument i think is that this now
needs to be considered as something
extending to television
and that there's an extraordinary new
opportunity for factual television and
you see it not not only on youtube which
i mentioned but also on on netflix
that the documentary uh is actually much
much more popular than you'd perhaps
expect on netflix
and we've got to be a little bit
cautious because netflix very much wants
people to watch documentaries because
they're less expensive to make you know
it's it's much better value it's rather
like spotify wants people to listen to
podcasts because you have fewer
royalties to pay than if people are
listening to music
but at the same time i think what is
interesting is something perhaps we fail
to notice adequately or which young
people won't notice at all which is that
the fact that you can watch video on
demand and you can pause it and you can
rewind it and you can watch it at any
time you like
is actually an extraordinary gift for
factual television because you couldn't
broadcast a two-hour documentary on how
to change the fuel pump on a 1987 toyota
camry in the age of broadcast television
that would have been intolerable to all
but 27 people
but in the age of youtube there are 27
people who find that the best tv they
can watch all
day and so you've been spending a lot of
time on youtube have you
well i suspect that
this is purely anecdotal but one of the
things i noticed after lockdown was
everybody had a kind of guilty
televisual secret and you know there
were some families who watched there was
some donkey cam which was just a live
broadcast of donkeys there's a very
enjoyable one which is actually the
alaskan bear cam
which is live footage of bears um
effectively by a waterfall in alaska
trying to catch salmon
and as i said you couldn't devote bbc
one not even bbc two or channel four to
you know hours of this content but it's
it became under lockdown and maybe will
stick afterwards peculiarly watchable
and i also think there's a kind of tv as
screensaver which is you can almost
consider your television to be a window
and if you're getting on with other work
you can either have a black rectangle on
the wall or you can have a live view of
a train station in boise idaho okay
and actually uh you know there are
suddenly new uses for television which i
don't think we're talking too much about
the metaverse and we're not talking
enough about what you might call the
reinvention of tv
uh i'd also say that the 4k tv
which makes the display of text
particularly attractive and readable i
actually read books on my television
oh wow i'm at that age now at 56 i have
you know presbyopia it's technically
called that effectively when people get
older they become more long-sighted and
that's happened to me
and so quite often i sit here in front
of me as a 55-inch 4k television and i
occasionally read kindle books on the tv
enormous type i mean you know and it's
pleasantly at sort of five feet from my
head rather than being two feet or three
feet from my head
and so actually you know the 4k
television combined with television on
demand and you know effectively
television delivered by internet
will create i think an explosion of new
uses of television yeah i mean that's
fair enough i mean
viewers of spectator tv will not be
strangers to youtube already because
that is where we are hosted but you also
write that a lot of things on youtube is
rubbish and they're only some divinely
good things like spectator tv of course
so how do you sift through all that
rubbish to find the good stuff that's
that's where the talent lies i think the
first thing i do at least temporarily
because you can get a free trial of
youtube premium okay which is ad free
youtube and you can get two months trial
of that for free now it's probably a
little bit difficult to cancel after
you've
after you've adopted the free trial but
i don't think it's impossible by any
means google is not quite as sludgy as
other content providers are in making it
impossible to cancel subscriptions
online which is a major problem actually
um but
the slight annoyance of ads on youtube
is not that they're ads
it tends to place ads in front of the
content
and if you're in the exploration mode
you don't want to listen to an ad for 30
seconds or whatever or if you're lucky
10 seconds every time you're just
experimenting because in that browsing
mode it becomes particularly tedious
it's fine if you're watching hour-long
things and you know what you want to
watch but it's annoying when you want to
explore so probably consider subscribing
to youtube premium if you've got youtube
on your tv
and the trick is actually searching
almost take the most obscure things you
can think of and search for them
which is and part of that's a kind of
it's a kind of knack
but you know if if you're if you're
particularly interested in uh you know
cricket
you know actually if you search for you
know obscure new zealand cricketers of
the 1980s or whatever you will find
something of surprising interest
if you're particularly interested in
fishing if you're particularly
interested in alboli try searching for
those things and you will almost always
not come up empty-handed
and then the trick is the other trick is
the use of the subscribe button so i
mean one of the things i don't think
we're very good at we have google and we
have youtube and actually
one of the most valuable things you can
do is get better at using google
realizing that if you want to search for
a phrase you put inverted commas double
inverted commas around the phrase if
there's a word that's essential you put
a plus before it and it will only show
you search results that contain that
word now most people don't know that
now in the same way i think on youtube
gaining the knack of subscribing to
things in particular when you when you
particularly like them
um and also
effectively putting yourself in a
slightly different mindset
which is that the television is
traditionally kind of lean back
entertainment you sit there and tell the
box to entertain you and actually you do
have to participate a little bit here
another thing that might make it better
if you have roku for example uh or if
you have amazon firestick or if you have
skype i think it's sky q
voice search is really good so literally
you know you can go on and just say
carrie grant
for example so you know what what i'm
saying is that most people i suspect
it's one of those things which it repays
it repays experimentation fairly quickly
but it is upfront weighted
and most people haven't gone through the
25 minutes or half an hour or hour of
bother
to find out sites to subscribe to
some of this stuff by the way is really
interesting that there's a site called a
channel called big jet tv on youtube
and they they
they go to airports around the world and
they film planes taking off and landing
now and what could be nerdier than that
but actually
during storm eunice
it was getting i think he got an
audience of a million or something at
one point because actually watching
planes struggle to it's perfect chardon
friday right watching planes struggle to
land in really heavy winds is actually
pretty damn enjoyable
and so you it does require no one's
going to tell you to do this
and it always strikes me as interesting
that most of these families under
lockdown discovered a kind of you know
what you might call slow tv dirty secret
james hoffman's reviews on making coffee
would be another example
and it is it is i mean i i think one of
the reasons people keep it secret is
this is a bit of a nerdy secret in
general
you know it's not you know it's not like
saying did you see game of thrones
saying did you watch bears try to catch
salmon for two hours last night isn't
quite the same water cooler moment but
it's still it's still really worthwhile
if you can if you can develop the skill
well rory sutherland thank you so much
for joining spectator tv on youtube
which i feel should be really sponsoring
us if anyone wants to get in contact
and do click subscribe and do click
subscribe that's quite right
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to the spectator's
youtube channel as rory advice just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon so
you never miss an episode thanks for
watching and do join us again next week
[Music]
you